you
let's run with d4 who here just got Juke
you're excited you are excited to see e4
and then you got Juke right there d4
Queens gambit accepted Slav land hmm
let's go he's gonna take here let's go
in this let's go with this line here I'm
not gonna be trying to get my bishop
outside the pawn chain so let's do this
and in this line what can I do I could
go after this light square bishop and I
think I'll do that try to get the bishop
pair he's the one piece that's going to
struggle to do something and is there
any good reason to delay this capture I
don't know about that this is basically
the a move I'll need to play soon enough
so we've clean here Queen to c2 doesn't
really matter much probably does what
about my bishop where does he belong or
this guy you know what I probably should
do that how descriptive was that line
right there I should do bat move yeah I
don't know well the reason I came to
that move was I really didn't want to go
about the deployment like this just sod
is too weakening and I'm not sure when
I'm with my bishop maybe I want to move
my queen let me baby step it here well
hang on
maybe I should consider taking here now
let's see how black responds to this if
Queen to b6 I think I have enough time
to get in the b5 break yes I would
Queen b6 c5 Queen takes pawn takes the
bishop moves b4 if a 6 I have B 5
because this rook is unprotected I could
take on b5 after C takes okay so clearly
not going in that direction but now the
Queen is here so should that really
matter much I think you know let's get
my bishop here I want to keep pressure
on d5 by keeping pressure here it means
that life is gonna be more difficult for
the c5 or a 5 breaks and if black really
wants to get it in then that means you
have to capture on c4 first I'm not sure
where my King belongs that I have to be
very careful if I go Kings side if he
goes Queen side I'll probably go Queen
side I need to be a little bit concerned
about g4 g5 this is a way to break down
this King side structure he's of course
a doubled pawns so it's quite reasonable
to go in that direction maybe we go to
opposite sides castling or actually no
why do we now now that I don't have to
be concerned about a rook over here
now I'm gonna decide on castling in this
direction there might be some sneaky
stuff against well I'm not gonna say I
might have some sneaky stuff just in
case my opponent is being sneaky and
strange sniping Nutkin I'm not gonna
save some trick I'll save it until after
the game there's something sneaky that I
might have available to me ah how about
that how do you meet a play on the wings
let's play in the center it's open stuff
up let's look look this guy Rumble in
fact that's not the primary reason I did
this but this is this is certainly
happening isn't it I'm threatening to
grab that pawn Byam my main idea was
just to challenge this pawn further open
up the position so they've given up
their central
most don't really have a better reply
than that all right so a bishop pair
open position I'm feeling a lot more
comfortable right now so my only concern
I want to keep him on this diagonal
however which diagonal or which square
along this diagonal is best probably
here Queen d3 is threatening maybe some
stuff on h7 one day I am still on this
pawn
if pawn push takes Knight here I think
this is a losing move I think I think it
is because my queen is just amazing is
that really the truth is that really the
case pawn takes Knight takes and then my
queen slides over because she's sneaky
over to age three she shows her strength
it really well from the age three square
seems uh seems pretty good
Bishop check King here what's the
follow-up not seeing it my queen will be
there to watch over each - what's the
story now Knight takes Queen takes f5 no
way you wouldn't do that would you
very weakening no we're about even on
time Queen d3 Queen h3 bishops pointing
at the King position I'm ready to maybe
throw a rock into the mix come it's
really coming at a snail's pace mmm
rook a1 to e1 e3 age 3 Queen on h4
checkmate on h8 how difficult can that
be don't try to think too many moves
ahead don't try to think too many ahead
get yourself in trouble miscalculate
focused on getting the first two moves
right if you're lucky all right well
it's a thinker I'm up on oh okay that's
very nice
um I actually I was thinking of that and
I thought Bishop here is that really
doing anything great huh how about rook
here we're about even on time there goes
my time advantage Oh pawn here pawn push
here Bishop takes pawn takes Knight that
might be decent let's go for it
why not mix things up he's gonna be an
animal on f6 isn't he animal office
color bishop bending he's gonna be tough
to defend though isn't he yes he is
Knight here if Bishop takes Queen H to
mate Knight here I'm almost always gonna
play Queen h3 Bishop takes pawn takes
I'm ready to blast up in the kingside
structure g6 might still be defendable
and then maybe my pawn can be tracked
down we're gonna see about that
soon how soon though oh really that
can't be right it really can okay hang
on for a second I really just want to
take that night let's take them and give
this intermediate check pawn push King
here rook here looking for me I'm not
gonna allow mate on the edge file am i
you gonna run home or to his Scout
castles square I should say alrighty so
he's clearly playing in fearless I was
know let's let's let's do this there's
no tricks here my Queens there to cover
oh he's a giant thorn you can't put a
price tag on that pond right there's no
way how much is he worth
how much too much he's worth too much I
want to get my Queen to h4 and that
should be game over this can't be bad no
way oh man
just clean here this should be leading
to Maine
if Pond takes I could eventually control
East seven with this let's let's see how
look good you could run here let's put
pressure and well for a second I thought
there was gonna be problems with age to
clean can't take because of pins stuff
now the king is run for his life running
for his life pretty much stuff oh my
goodness are you kidding me I almost had
an Adobe experience I didn't mean to go
there okay Paula okay finally finally
everything's falling can't go there
Natan - one two three
well that's me yeah that King got
flushed out there but uh good game let's
go back hmm
good game not the first time we've
played and not the first good game that
uh my opponent played let's let's see
what we had here this love all right I'm
very familiar with this for black I
probably do it too much probably do it
too much well you do get that Bishop
outside the pawn chain but you also have
to be content with giving him up because
of how white can follow up with the
knight to h4 so still looking for or
what what am I trying to do on the white
side here I'm trying to come up with
some imbalance because not much going on
just yet in fact maybe if I don't go for
this or I mean there's still other
things I you have your problem Bishop
already solved he's outside of your pawn
chain where he still has to work but
okay nevertheless I I went forward with
this I went after the light square
bishop
and h3 they go hand in hand just as you
would with fee encountering a bishop
moving the pond playing Bishop g7 if
you're gonna take the bishop here the
natural follow up with that is going to
be to push I'm actually looking at it a
bit closer right now and I wonder if
there's a way to really get this type of
advance in quickly is that something
that black has available maybe did I do
this maybe too quickly maybe there's a
reason actually hold up I was talking
about how they go hand in hand but maybe
I should be bringing to question the
timing of such a move I wonder if that
does allow for a quick strike with g4 I
mean I could be watching over it's not
that big of a deal
like if g5 is played I could play here
maybe it take and then if I recapture
then you're back what's doing this move
I'm not sure I think eventually though
this is gonna have to be played you can
envision a queen or Bishop functioning
on this diagonal quite natural squares
ties in well with that rook on h8 but
okay
pretty common moves I'm pretty sure well
I don't know about my Queen move but as
far as the black setup that doesn't seem
too bad where's where's there something
more to do oh I was I was saying that
after the game I was gonna point out the
sneaky thing that I had available you
know what it was it was this not that
it's anything brilliant but here's
there's a particular tactic to be aware
of in this in this opening where White
has the bishop pair where you go into
this line where you're capturing on g6
out of the Slav here it's a situation
where let's say at this point black
captures on c4 I could be taking with my
queen and when I do that I'm already
threatening Bishop takes pawn sometimes
just because it's because of the pin on
this f7 pawn excuse me
after instead of g5
if takes Queen here I was saying that
keeping pressure on d5
really makes life difficult with the
pawn breaks for black with e5 or c5 and
so if you're gonna try to get one of
them in you'd have to give up your your
central point on d5 most likely and so
if you do do that here takes Queen takes
this particular pond advance is not
working because that would make the pawn
on f7 pin to the king which allows for
Bishop takes g6 you could see some
variations of that if my queen initially
deployed to c2 then after a capture
there's Bishop here similarly after E 5
it would now be the bishop pinning the
pond and you can see the Queen coming
down capturing on g6 anyhow that didn't
even show itself in this game but it's a
it's a tactic to certainly be aware of
and I think um I think something else
needs to be done besides g5 here I think
if I'm getting an e4 the positions
opening up the bishop hair thrives and
there's you know the other other
criteria to be looking into and III
don't know I have the bishop I'd have
the bishop pair the position is open
there's no time edge really for either
side it seems like there maybe should be
something better here although it's
tough because I'm ready to do this on my
next move and how are you gonna get your
pawn break in I wonder if there's I
wonder if it's better to have the Queen
on a different square I wonder if she
was better placed on e7 maybe if she's
on e7 playing the c5 move would be a
little bit easier somehow like cuz
you're never really able to do this move
because it might be five I'm wondering
about the Queen's place but I really
don't have the answers obviously
although Queen c7 was played for a very
important reason right you had to watch
over b7 I really sure what to suggest
here hmm
I don't know because it really seems to
start turning my way as soon as I get a
four and takes Queen takes maybe takes
Queen takes and then there's night here
this square I don't know feel free to
leave some suggestions on the hide I
really just don't know okay yeah it's I
do have that [ __ ] of hairs there's some
tactic that might have been missed now
that it's getting very violent not very
violent but it's certainly more opened
with more possibilities now hmm yeah I
wonder if you could get away with taking
takes and then drop the Bishop back it
does look scary though having upon an f6
you know yeah I think something other
than this cuz I'm not sure what it what
it should be but I think it says runs
the risk of just losing some material
losing a pawn in this case maybe maybe
there is something to capturing and then
trying to get a Knight to d5 you can't
say for sure but I don't know I just
want her to trade a little bit maybe
there was even something better I'm not
sure not sure I know I have a slight
material plus turned out to to be enough
there yeah I guess maybe pawn up King g7
would be the the best try and then
keeping pressure on this pond still
trying to fight on despite being down
upon g6 King g7 but I think we were
quite low on time he's just too much of
a thorn on that g6 square alrighty good
game as usual
you